Im Zollmuseum von Habkirchen hat
Franz-Josef Fries alle Hände voll zu tun.
Der pensionierte Zöllner kümmert sich
ehrenamtlich um die Ausstellung
im alten Grenzhäuschen.
Eigentlich ist die deutsch-französische
Grenze hier Geschichte,
das Museum ein Symbol
für gute Nachbarschaft.
Doch jetzt hat die Corona-Krise einen Keil
in die länderübergreifende
Freundschaft getrieben.
Dass ich das noch erleben kann,
dass Deutsche mit den Franzosen
irgendwelchen Krach haben,
nur weil sie aus Frankreich kamen,
weil in Frankreich Corona eher war.
Das hätte ich nie im Leben geglaubt,
dass das wieder passiert.
Franzosen werden beschimpft, stehen in
Verdacht, das Virus zu verbreiten,
als im März die Grenzen wieder geschlossen
werden – so wie diese Brücke.
Eine deutsche Behörde hatte die französische
Nachbarregion zum Risikogebiet erklärt.
Nur wer auf der anderen Seite arbeitete,
durfte die Grenze weiter passieren.
Eine Maßnahme, für die
Franz-Josef Fries Verständnis hat.
Was wollten Sie denn machen?
Natürlich, ein Virus macht an
keiner Grenze der Welt halt.
Die Leute, die rüberkommen mit dem
Virus, die verbreiten den dann.
Ihn hat das schwer getroffen: Jerome
Lohmann ist Franzose,
pendelt zur Arbeit nach Deutschland.
Dann war über Nacht die Grenze zu,
ohne Ankündigung.
Als Grenzgänger durfte er zwar rüber.
Doch mancher Deutsche sah
plötzlich eine Gefahr in ihm.
Wenn wir gesagt kriegen, wir sind jetzt
unerwünscht und alles,
und das war – das hat mir ein
bisschen Weh am Herz gemacht.
Wie? Warum? Wir können nichts dafür. Jeder
weiß, es kommt ja von China.
Das hätten können die deutschen
Kollegen kriegen oder egal was.
Und wir können nichts dafür. Das hat
mir doch ein bisschen wehgetan.
Im deutschen Grenzort Gersheim hat der
Bürgermeister selbst französische Wurzeln,
wie man schon an seinem Namen merkt.
Michael Clivot hat die Berichte gelesen von
Grenzgängern aus Frankreich,
die auf der Straße als
„Scheißfranzosen“ beschimpft wurden,
die in ihr „Corona-Land“ zurückgehen sollten.
Ausgerechnet im frankophilen Saarland
steht die deutsch-französische
Freundschaft auf dem Prüfstand.
In dieser Krise hat sich tatsächlich gezeigt,
dass sie vielleicht doch nicht so stabil ist,
wie wir das uns bisher immer
vorgestellt haben und auch gewünscht haben.
Und ich glaube, dass wir jetzt einiges
auch noch mal tun müssen,
um zumindest mal bei den
Menschen vor Ort dieses Gefühl,
dass die Partnerschaft so wichtig für Europa
ist, noch mal tatsächlich aufzubauen.
Michael Clivot hat das Verhalten seiner
Saarländer öffentlich kritisiert.
Und jetzt steht er selbst in der Kritik.
Mir hat man tatsächlich
Fakenews hier vorgeworfen,
weil viele das auch nicht wahrhaben
wollten, aber ich glaube, es war wichtig,
das auch laut und stark zu sagen,
dass wir hier ein Problem haben.
Jetzt, wo die Grenze endlich wieder geöffnet
ist, will der Deutsche ein Zeichen setzen,
besucht seinen französischen
Amtskollegen im benachbarten Rimling.
Eric Hemmert erlebt die Freundschaftskrise
von der französischen Seite.
Er fürchtet, die Reaktionen aus Deutschland
könnten Narben hinterlassen.
Das hat ein Klima
des Misstrauens geschaffen.
In gewisser Weise hat uns
unsere Geschichte wieder eingeholt.
Da ist bei dem einen oder anderen plötzlich
wieder der Extremismus hochgekommen.
Das Denkmal von Rimling
zeugt von der Geschichte
einer schwer umkämpften Grenzregion,
von den Kriegen zwischen beiden Staaten.
Eine Mahnung für Politiker beider Seiten,
sagen die Bürgermeister.
So manche unbedachte Äußerung
habe die Krise verschärft.
Die politische Rhetorik beeinflusst auch
das Handeln der Menschen
und wie sie mit der Angst auch,
die im Moment da ist, auch umgehen.
Und wenn man natürlich
über Wochen erzählt,
dass man die
Saarländerinnen und Saarländer
vor den Franzosen schützen muss, dann
fangen natürlich die Menschen an,
drüber nachzudenken, und kommen dann
vielleicht zu irrationalem Handeln,
und das haben wir hier auch gehabt.
So bekommt das alte Schild der europäischen
Freundschaftsbrücke in Habkirchen
wieder besondere Bedeutung.
Franz-Josef Fries, der ehemalige Zöllner,
hätte es am liebsten wieder am alten Platz.
Eine Freundschaft, die so fest war
wie Deutschland und Frankreich,
die gewachsen ist über Jahrzehnte,
wirklich über Jahrzehnte,
die macht man durch
so ’n Quatsch nicht kaputt.
Dass das jetzt bleibende Schäden hat, also,
das kann ich mir beim allerbesten Willen
nicht vorstellen. Absolut nicht.
Im kleinen Museum von Franz-Josef Fries
wird die Corona-Blockade
jedenfalls ihren Platz finden:
als ein neues Stück
deutsch-französischer Grenzgeschichte.